well it was really cool to see all the
Halloween decorations that your viewers
send in to us but for Halloween night we
really wanted to show you a house that's
unlike any other when it comes to really
scary decorations Victoria Saha gives us
a look at a house where the ghosts and
goblins will be staying put in Astoria
you'll only see on eight news now
[Music]
from the Southeast Valley where
Halloween is all year long you have to
see it to believe it
for David Perry there was hardly any
need to put up Halloween decorations I
I dreamed of living in a haunted house
one
turning his love for Halloween into
something he can experience every day
growing up Halloween was the one day a
year where I could be anything that I
wanted to be I could let loose I could
act the way I want to act Harry has
skeletons that have made their way out
of the closet
and they're built in everywhere the best
part about it is I had no particular
design I just did this randomly just as
I went including this real skeleton that
was donated to a research center then
given to Perry this is Bob down down
here Bob currently watches whatever I
watch on TV even his kitchen screams
Halloween Perry bought this house in
2015. 25 000 later you can't even
believe it's the same house a lot of
people go on vacation and we decided to
make our home the home that we want to
go to vacation to only enter if you dare
Victoria Saha 8 News Now